despite their pain these witnesses
expressed their strong desire
to share their stories with this
committee and the public
they have all been broken by gun
violence
and in person or via video link they
shared their stories
the doctor
the mother the parents
the survivor
and then she went
back in the room
her name is maya cerrillo and she
survived a horror which took 19 of her
classmates and her two teachers
and he went to there and
saw my teacher and told my teacher
tonight and shot her in the head
and then he shot
some of my classmates
and the whiteboard
politicians from all sides in this
debate listened as they weigh up how or
even if gun laws across this nation
should change miguel is maya's father
hello today
i come
because that girl lost my baby girl
she's not the same little girl that i
used to play with ingram with
and do everything because she was
daddy's little girl
felix and kimberly were there for their
daughter lexi
we don't want you to think of lexi as
just a number
she was intelligent compassionate and
athletic
she was quiet
shy unless she had a point to make
but she knew she was right she so often
was
then the uvalde doctor roy guerrero
two children whose bodies have been
pulverized by bullets fired at them
decapitated
whose flesh had been ripped apart
that the only clue at their identities
was a blood splattered cartoon clothes
still clinging to them
clinging for life and finding none
they're dead because restrictions have
been allowed to lapse they're dead
because there are no rules about where
guns are kept because no one is paying
attention to who is buying them
the thing i can't figure out is whether
our politicians are failing us out of
stubbornness
passivity or both
but then listen to this mother lucretia
hughes her son was shot in the head
but she doesn't think more gun laws are
the answer
how about let me defend myself from evil
i
you don't think that i'm capable
and trustworthy to handle a firearm
you don't think that the second
amendment doesn't apply to people that
look like me
and there it is the gulf that exists
here such starkly different solutions
for an all-american problem
outside in the heart of this nation's
capital the numbers in flowers
since uvalde two weeks ago more than 700
have been killed in gun violence mark
stone sky news in washington